madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
voici les principaux titres de
l'actualité
d'abord qu'est ce tu fais là jean-claude
c'est pas de 20 heures mais non c'est
pas du tout le 21 lacets touche pas à
mon poste france 4 à la célèbre émission
qui cartonne louis basse et sa fondation
et des matchs qui se piquerait jean
claude bourret c'est parti
[Musique]
merci votre avec nous je pense qu'un
seul rendez vous touche pas à mon poste
vous venez d'intégrer le groupe de
touche pas à mon poste qu'est ce que ce
groupe c'est un groupe dans lequel on
pense qu'on peut rire de la télévision
est blonde en a marre des émissions
médias sérieuse n'est ce pas le public
et s'il faut rire alors on nous demande
souvent peut-on rire de tout en tout cas
une chose est sûre on peut rire de la
télévision et on va en rire ce soir
regardez ce qui vous attend dans touche
pas à mon poste il va y avoir un crétin
qui va s'emparer cette phrase et qui va
dire en 6 lalanne parle avec les ronces
je suis un crétin de la télé alors avec
francis lalanne on est deux on s'en fout
quand on est des crétins il m'a pris le
brun comme ça la main de moundir pas ça
mon foot qu'ibra tuer je t'aime autant
vous dire que je les ai sentis faisaient
autant la barre de fer vous aviez dit
que vous ne referiez plus jamais de télé
ce soir vous êtes avec nous pourquoi
et bien tout simplement parce que vous
me l'avez demandé et ben voilà alors de
ce côté on aime tous de ce côté il ya
que de nyc & corporate forcément
ça va faire du bien mais laurent
saulnier dégustation jésus et de colère
ouais je sais pas ce que nous cache de
mam en tout cas pour l'instant ça sent
très bon dead 2 qui ont accepté vous et
raymond domenech n'avait toute l'équipe
qui te suit sur france 4 aussi un camp
si vous avez tout à fait raison ça
wallon pour échelonner avec mes quatre
fans qui me suivent partout
et voilà merci d'être là voilà c'était
ce qui vous attend ce soir dans tout ce
pas mon poste tombe accompagné dans
cette mission de se divertir autour de
la télévision
tanguy pastureau qui est avec nous ce
soir j'ai envie parce que vous êtes
barman juste après voilà je fais tout
d'abord valises et bien je le vois très
bien j'aime beaucoup notre soleil de
l'émission elodie gossuin
très belle robe la compagnie créole 82
j'adore si les mots thierry lorho télé 7
jours
merci d'être ici c'est un plaisir vous
êtes le plus chic de l'émission euros
oui je me suis dit qu'il y mettre une
cravate je me démarque comme un petit
peu tout le monde vous vous démarquez je
vous le confirme si tu es avec nous
également jean michel maire on peut dire
avec cigare ou qui les fait rêver
d'avoir ça va bientôt michel cabaret
punk fonctionne merci jean michel et
enfin christophe carrière de l'ex spice
est également choisi officiel capillaire
de jean michel jarre
merci d'être avec nous tanguy pastureau
qui chaque semaine va prendre des images
qui n'ont aucun intérêt à la télévision
et grâce à ces commentaires va les
rendre vraiment intéressant est ce qu'il
ya des images qui ont un intérêt à la
télévision de juin bah oui quand même
attendez on aime la télévision s'en
moque mais on aime bien faire c'est vrai
donc enfin un petit gîte et le jt du
poste et tanguy pastureau ça s'appelle
un pastureau sinon rien
[Musique]
merci mais je n'ai encore rien dit on
commence cette semaine avec le grand
journal de canal+ de papy denisot qui a
invité papy sarkozy le peintre pal
sarkozy on disait que nicolas sarkozy
vous savez le fils du peintre un petit
peu moins connus n'avait pas entendu le
mécontentement des français aux
régionales qu'il était sourd comme un
pot et ben on sait d'où ça vient
pensez-vous président jamais je suis un
peu saoulant quoi tient team devons
qu'elle lui avait transmis à mon fils
mais je crois j'ai transmis sur tous les
goûts du tendre à et passe et 1 contre
bayonne alors vous veillez en
arrière-plan nous pouvons voir une
croûte de pal sarkozy ça ressemble aux
croûtes qu'on a sur la peau quand on se
lave pas mais avec plus de couleurs
c'est le type qui s'appelle pâle
atteindre autant de couleurs vives
pal c'est son prénom et son deuxième
prénom c'est ccam ses toiles sont
spéciales on les reconnaît du premier
coup on appelle ça le pedigree pâle
dans son court 100 mag sur m6 on nous a
parlé d' usurpation d'identité des
salles des stars internationales se font
piquer leur identité par des [ __ ]
d'anonymes tard américaines ne sont pas
les seuls à subir ce type de désagrément
bonsoir en france l'animateur magloire a
été la victime d'un usurpateur
malgré tout alors mis au courant de
l'existence d'un manoir sur facebook
année ça passe ça avec ma photo qui
existent et se sont fait usurper leur
identité
eva mendes jennifer lopez george clooney
zh
chez nous en france bernard menez ou
magloire la star magloire quoi le
présentateur de tous ses succès telecom
et enfin magloire quoi vous devriez vous
méfier
cyril 1 il faudrait que sur la trois oui
bien un mec qui est comme vous
physiquement beau gosse un peu frime et
qui chantent tous les samedis soirs avec
la fille de charlie oleg ça peut vous
porter préjudice au sort a toujours je
me méfie sinon jean pierre pernaut
vendredi nous ça complètement plombé
l'ambiance et on revient et en même
temps les français ont à nouveau le
moral en berne
l'indicateur mensuel de l'insee sur le
moral des ménages le confirme ce matin
'l'annonce d'une très forte hausse du
prix du gaz de presque 10% n'arrange
rien pouvoir d'achat emploi pour loyer
on pense qu'à ça à lyon galles charnay
jo erik guay les seuls à faire présenter
un sujet super a plombé par jan erik
guay a les directions koh lanta le choc
koh-lanta il ya deux équipes d'un côté
des sportifs à la retraite de l'autre
des schizophrènes traité
christina est l'une de ces malades une
partie de moi qui me dieu stop on arrête
arrive à trouver si je vois pas pourquoi
tu y as encore liv des souffrances à
orthez bien chez toi et tout est et
l'autre partie qui me jb j'ai pas le
droit de baisser les bras par apport à
par rapport à mes proches et on se
demande quelles parties de christina va
aller le plus loin être schizophrène à
la télé c'est important tenez moi je
suis schizo et bien pendant que je fais
cette chronique ici en même temps je
suis chez cauet ceci dit cette édition
de koh lanta a été conçu par des
personnes pour les personnes à double
personnalité
en fait il ya de jeu il ya kho lanta et
collants tôt
c'est tout la gagnante de koh lanta 2009
l'île de koh lanta c'est l'île de lost
c'est aussi compliqué on ne sait pas
quand on est dans koh lanta qu'on est
dans koh lanta
christina était la même personne que
christine oghly pastureau est ce que si
je vais à koh lanta je serai tanguy
pastureau attention accès privé cette
semaine est parti en forêt avec francis
lalanne qui fait des bisous aux arbres
et qui caresse les ronces pourquoi les
ronces n'aurait pas droit aux caresses
aussi après il va y avoir un crétin qui
va s'emparer cette phrase et qui va dire
francis lalanne parle avec les ronces
tous à la télévision évidemment les
routes c'est compliqué pour un mec comme
moi tu pas tomber dans le piège non et
puis il faut pas juger parce qu'on sait
pas ce que lui ont répondu les orties et
les petites bêtes qui paraît qu discuter
avec une fougère c'est vraiment
intéressant et puis bon voilà ton puis
je suis un crétin de la télé alors avec
francis lalanne on est deux on s'en fout
quand on est décrétant et bah écoutez ça
nous fait plaisir merci
tanguy pastureau qui sera toutes les
semaines pour un pastureau si l'on est à
mon avis on va se faire des ennemis
ça va aller très très mal pour vous
accueillir maintenant un des animateurs
les plus grands de la télévision
française 1 m 93 et celui aussi qui fait
le plus d'audience avec koh lanta 8
millions 3 à la semaine dernière denis
brogniart est avec nous ce soir sur le
plateau
merci d'être avec nous de nintendo
bonsoir à tous fonnière habité de touche
pas à mon poste il est un honneur pour
nous aussi on plus on a pris quelqu'un
qui faisait beaucoup d'audience a
cartonné la semaine dernière koh lanta
heureusement que t'as pas commencé la
semaine dernière
il aurait pu inviter le choc des héros
alors on a appris que moi c'était la
bonne nouvelle franck leboeuf a gagné
parce que je l'en franchement j'étais en
train de le soutenir la semaine dernière
jalil soutenir cette semaine au moins je
vais pouvoir regarder l'émission
tranquille je sais que c'est franck
leboeuf qui a gagné qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire de dire c'est que
franck leboeuf était un grand
communicant et qu'il répond à un certain
nombre d'interviews il confond tout ce
qui fait en ce moment où tu sais il est
à la fois au théâtre à caen joue une
pièce est à paris et puis il est dans
koh lanta donc
donc en fait il a gagné le théâtre voilà
il a gagné le théâtre pour l'instant
rien sur koh lanta il va falloir
patienter
c'est tous les vendredis soir sur tf1 en
prime je suis sûr que tu seras devant
ton poste pour savoir si effectivement
bien sûr leurs amis leboeuf à gagner
pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas koh
lanta regardez à quoi ça ressemble ça
existe depuis 10 ans et ça cartonne
le lagon peu profonds qui entourent
l'îlot des malabou est un bonheur pour
ces jeunes requins une véritable
pouponnière à squale ça commence les
emmerdes
mais je le savais pas qu'on compte
troussel qui soient ramenés du jeu chez
paquet tempête
c'est un enfer j'ai pour lui de partir
ça fait trois jours vous allez
maintenant tous individuellement voté à
bulletins secrets en votre âme et
conscience et l'un d'entre vous va être
éliminé
[Musique]
c'est ça qu'on l'entend moi j'adore élu
par vécu mais j'adore kolontar
je n'en manque pas un qui regarde koh
lanta ici autour de la table rase
thierry moreau surtout quand il me
regarde pas cela sur le sida sortez
couverts ça va bien avec tous voila
c'est pour le chapon sap est couvert en
période du sidaction c'est très bas
souligne jean-michel il ya quelque chose
qui est choquant quand on regarde les
images comme ça c'est que de limogne à
c'est aussi une voix c'est que dès que
ça commence maintenant la voie est
maintenant on peut fermer les yeux on
voit les images que c'est absolument
incroyable
animateurs qui ont une voix aussi
pertinente aussi reconnaissable il a il
a joué et les cheveux non mais là les
gars parce que tu as essayé de
moderniser un peu mais avant tu étais
comme moi oui mais j'aime bien j'aime
bien non il ya un petit coin tout cas
tous les douces et vous êtes encore les
grans welt est lancée avec les cheveux
frisés enfin ça généraux free veut dire
quoi c'est la passion j'aime regarder
koh lanta mais je regardais les témoins
c'était mon bonheur de l'été maintenant
elles ont misé au printemps mais non
j'ai eu deux recrues ce nom il ya bien
un être humain
bah ouais moi c'est l'été je regardais
ça ce témoin mon bonheur de l'été je
pense que si tf1 pouvait mettre que koh
lanta toute l'année tandis que c'est la
seule émission qui cartonne en divers
qui mettrait koh-lanta c'est ça ou pas
de liste non parce que l'été faut que je
parte en vacances et ça doit vous zappez
denis tu veux pas offert de g.collomb
pas non mais va lui ont fait un petit
mars avril là ça serait sympa
alalalala au vote du conseil je voudrais
connaître le taux d'abstention c'est
vrai que c'est une bonne question jamais
un candidat dit non je ne vote pas ce
soir ah ouais c'est pas comme original
exact on nous a posé la question de
savoir si le vote blanc et est autorisé
bien évidemment il ne l'est pas dans le
commentaire mais même s'il m'arrive quoi
alors si votre blanc on l'a on les vire
ils sont virés ils sont virés gto ternir
en colère il a voté
elles m'ont dit en colère il a voté je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez vous dire
en colère il n'a pas voulu que je lui
étais n'y sa flamme oui c'est vrai il
m'a pris le bras comme ça la main de
moundir face à mon petit bras flux et je
fais autant vous dire que je les sens si
possible encore la barque l'accord
et à ce moment là la seule chose que
j'ai trouvée parce qu'il me dit non non
non non je veux bien que tu étais à 9
l'âme mais on va dans la forêt imaginez
c'est comme ce plateau là il ya quand
même huit ou neuf caméras on peut pas
partir dans la forêt comme ça en
freestyle toxiques y salue faire c'est
trouver une idée pour qu'ils puissent
accepter que j'éteigne sa flamme je me
suis dit tiens là tu es dos aux
aventuriers qui t'ont éliminé si je te
mettais de fass est finie vous allez
être face à ceux qui vous ont éliminé et
l'allemagne est d'accord et ça et ça
c'est dans le bouquin ça c'est dans ce
but qu'a jamais vu ça c'est la lecture
du bouquin les secrets de koh lanta on
en parlera tout à l'heure du livre de
denis brogniart quand on reçoit un
invité forcément on va sur internet pour
chercher des infos on va jouer à l'info
mito sur denis brogniart je vous donnais
des infos vous me dit qu'elles sont
vraies c'est sûr denis première info
denis brogniart est un professionnel du
bouche-à-bouche puisqu'il a été maître
nageur info ou mytho mythomane hôpitaux
tony mito faux maîtres nageurs ça ça me
déçoit à toi je vais te montrer mais
avec un peu de fond à dire mais oui j'ai
été manager je suis toujours mais dans
la bouche à bouche pour être maître
nageur il faut être sur un réanimateur
souris synchroniseur il a pratiqué la
natation à haut niveau en club de
besançon
si oui mais peu importe c'est ce qu'on
dit c'est ce qu'on lit ainsi le niveau
régional est un haut niveau alors
peut-être pour tester une épreuve de koh
lanta denis à manger lui-même des
tarentules et des verts vivant info
mytho bref oui thierry info d'accord 1
faute pour tout le monde sauf aux audi
c'est vrai test les épreuves denis
brogniart alors pas toutes au niveau de
la dégustation j'ai évité l'oeil de ton
de tongres certains colère ouais
pourquoi pas le ton est plutôt ça dépend
des années et c'est vrai que l'oeil de
ton la nuit avait été peut-être un peu
plus courte et quand je suis arrivé et
que j'ai vu sur cette assiette cet oeil
de cette taille-là sanguinolent parce
que c'était du thon rouge à l'époque
c'était franchement pas terrible que
j'allais essayer précédemment dans une
autre émission que je présentais fear
factor facteurs l'oeil d'autruche à
l'oeil d'autres jeux voilà ce qui était
pas très ragoûtant mais finalement il
faut imaginer qu'un oeil fait c'est ni
plus ni moins qu'un bout de cartilage de
poulet avec l'eau de le goût de l'eau
salée bah merci terrible denis roy jason
day
si je vous invite à dîner un de libre
d'y aller après avoir bouclé la sixième
saison de koh lanta denis brogniart a
décidé d'appeler une de ses filles
vanuatu infos ou vito mito mais n'ont
pas été bons rien que dans la peinture
et de la question à tous et des taxes
allez une petite dernière sur le
tournage de qui peut battre benjamin
castaldi animé par denis brogniart la
production a décidé de couper une scène
dans laquelle benjamin perdez un test de
qi face à un enfant de ce1 tout faux ou
mytho veau de lait mito mythos est un
mythe aux applaudissements pour nous
il va avoir un rituel dans cette
émission à chaque fois qu'on va recevoir
un invité on va aller voir les gens dans
la rue et leur demander ce qu'ils
pensent de cette personne en un mot donc
on l'a fait pour vous denis brogniart ça
évoque quoi pour les téléspectateurs ou
pas non ça se passe devant audard dans
un présentateur télé réalité formula
commente un aventurier très courageux je
connais pas quelqu'un d'humain qui est
proche du public sportif le superficiel
gérait aventuriers reprises et j'aime
beaucoup la beaucoup de charme
indépendant grag allait décoller sera
pas la tête sont vus assez dynamique que
sympa personne juste oui ils échouent et
que ces petites bouclettes l'un
professionnel qui peut les miens sont
sans d'affaires et dirait un petit
mouton un petit bouton situé allée faire
c'est toi qui es petit mouton regardez
les résultats du sondage 1 denis
brogniart en septième position les
téléspectateurs pensent que vous êtes
j'aime sa vie aux dites j'aime sa vie ne
le connais pas friser en cinquième
position car et frisés beau gosse grand
aventurier est en première position
on pense que vous êtes sympathique si ça
vous fait plaisir
il ya 5 % de gens qui ne vous
connaissent pas c'est pas rien c'est
bien c'est franchement c'est une ville
très flatté grand pour 20% je vous
confirme ahmed 96 aventuriers pourquoi
vous parlez pas de beau gosse tout de
suite si beau gosse soit 10 % quand même
une personne sur 10 vous trouve beau
gosse c'est bien c'est mieux que moi
c'est une personne sur mille ça veut
dire que 90 %
non ça veut dire non non ça va minimiser
attention les sondages tient pas là ça
veut dire que 90 %
voilà l'aiment bien pourrait passer une
nuit avec lui mais pas koh lanta voilà
je crois que c'est ça c'est bien résumé
c'est déjà dur et c'est d'accord chaque
semaine dans cette émission va retrouver
un garçon qui s'appelle yann stotz et
qui s'incruste dans toutes les émissions
du paf ça s'appelle le parasite du post
regardez
[Musique]
où
le couple ont tout de suite marie-rose
voyelles e voyelles une voyage à
voyelles à noyelles y voyelles aux
voyelles e voyelles à et voyelles et
[Musique]
après peut-être dû prendre une consonne
shi
daniel par my past concentré
[Musique]
marie-rose cette scène celui lui trop
tard avec moi j'ai vu le 8 attend donc
huit lettres pour moi oui avec m
c'est un oiseau du portugal oui vous
l'avez ah bon et bien sûr comme ça oui
d'accord c'est alors il ya le doute
était quoi c'était sur ayew nous
annoncer ça oui
ces rafles et vous savez pas ce que vous
avez accepté de jouer avec cyril hanouna
c'est vrai c'est vrai que ça va pas être
facile il y en a deux qui ont accepté
vous et raymond domenech mais toute
l'équipe qui te suit sur france 4 aussi
quand vous avez tout à fait raison ça
wallon pour échanger avec mes quatre
fans qui me suivent partout
voilà merci d'être là on y va on y va à
landiras retire j'ai voté pour betty ses
deux filles b team est vrai que je fasse
un choix
au jour d'aujourd'hui je pense que tu es
juste un tout petit peu en dessous du
haut niveau au niveau du physique
j'avais voté pour surya bonaly
et pendant cette émission tension du
sportif
là dedans
alors ça ça va être toutes les semaines
ça va vraiment devenir un rendez vous
très bon on ne touche pas à mon poste
c'est excellent ça vraiment bravo yann
stotz ce garçon aime tous dans cette
émission est d'ailleurs c'est l'intello
de l'émission l'appel l'intello du post
c'est jean michel maire cette semaine il
s'est intéressé amundi répond un intello
s'intéressait à mounir sais quelque
chose n'est ce pas jean michel serra est
tombé c'est de décrypter ou en tout cas
d'honorer ceux qui sont distingués un
peu dans la semaine par leur sortie
alors ça y est un peu verbal est
évidemment dès qu'on parle de saillies
verbales pour ça les talons moundir les
talons de du paf
voilà qui s'est illustré donne il le
sait mieux que personne déjà à koh lanta
candidats valeureux illustré par des
parts des remarques incroyable genre
tiens ta femme qu'ils avaient dit qu'ils
avaient fait ça en son honneur de gloire
hélas ici illustrée dans un programme
qui viennent et diffusé sur tmc et qu'a
connu son épilogue la semaine dernière
mundy moundir cherche l'amour est là on
va découvrir quelques extraits parce
qu'il est quand même très celui de
guerre en électricité
c'est en a consommé mais
non non
les rues de new york je voulais qu'elle
sorte ma présence et qu'elles se sentent
rassurés parmi tout ce monde là qu'elle
se sente choyés alors on a vous de me le
dire monsieur du paf
thierry moreau quel est le titre exact
d'une usine l'aventurier de l'amour
déjà évidemment à koh lanta j'ai conclu
avec maman cherche l'amour de recherche
vous le dire mais ça n'a rien à voir
ça c'est les les commandes qui cherche
lui dire mais pour l'instant personne ne
le cherche mais en tout cas on a vu
quand même sur tm 6 on est quand même
mis les gros moyens quand ils sont
partis à miami avec limousine jet privé
l'affût du parachutisme
il avait une vie la sublime 16,1 à
autour de lui là il est parti à new york
il a quand même tout il à times square
est entourée des plus jolies filles et c
est le seul truc qui me préoccupe c'est
les ampoules qu'hier jeudi les maires ça
va consommer à mort s'est cassé en le
mec il déjà on a dépensé beaucoup
d'argent pour moi évidemment qu'ils se
préoccupent du compteur électrique
mais d'ailleurs ça me fait penser à
donner parce que tout le monde sait ou
presque qui a rencontré son ca son
épouse sa charmante épouse géant
commenta comment quand vous avez fait
vous pour la pour la charmée sur le jeu
parce que vous aviez d'autres choses
ont-elles j'imagine que vous avez dû
mener à la fois le jeu et ont une temps
le jeu de la séduction comme chez pas
faire deux choses à la fois ggg opérer
cette séduction avant le début du jeu
j'avais toujours cinq six jours avant le
début du tournage et c'est à ce
moment-là que j'ai réussi à séduire
est-ce que vous avez séduit votre chance
et comme comme dans koh lanta c'est à
dire vous avez les mêmes codes c'est à
dire quand vous lui parlez chéri la
sentence est irrévocable
alors ce kit vous non chérie
prends ton sac va récupérer ton flambeau
et vient bregeon
non on a vu que mon ami avait réglé les
problèmes d'électricité maintenant il va
s'attaquer à la maçonnerie on va monter
un échafaudage et d'avoir fait des
bonnes fondations avec clémence
je sais pas ce que nous cachent deux
mamans en tout cas pour l'instant ça
sent très bon sa peau la foire peut
décrypter faut savoir que quand on est
sur tmc et donc du groupe tf1
on a quand même comme propriétaire
évidemment boeing donc là on se doit de
renvoyer l'ascenseur en permanence en
faisant des petites métaphore un peu du
bpp donc l'électricité donc là on a bien
compris maintenant c'est la maçonnerie
dans quoi me said et hop il est au point
bon bah un troisième extrait mis
d'accord rendu compte que c'était
important après les ja isle et il a
embrasé tout les a là mais c'est l'autre
la toile à trois ans que tout la fête
ça fait c'est la fête mais direct pour
trouver une nana genre faire un choix
que tu passes du taux paroxysme cette
extraordinaire on a dernière extrêmes ce
que celui ci tourne en boucle
c'est au dernier au début de l'aventuré
ceux qui ont vu ils n'ont pas pu
s'empêcher de leur passé en finale
est ce que c'est vraiment ça montre un
personnage comme tout en sensibilité
chanter de faire ta connaissance qu'est
ce qui t'a fait alors venir ici
pour venir me voir ben parce que tu me
plais d'accord pour moi une femme je
trouve ça très beau parce que
on dit souvent que les portes du paradis
se trouve sous les pieds de la maman là
toute femme deviendra meilleur un jour
en tout cas même si elle ne vient pas
elle elle adopte et c'est là vraiment
que j'ai compris que j'avais bien fait
de venir
pour les amoureux l'émission qui n'ont
pas suivi après l'on gagne un voyage
mais malheureusement le coût de ces
brisé avant qu'il parte d'un mois le
temps de mettre les pieds dans l'avion
s'est brisé et les moi aussi je suis
line donc moi je prends ça mais vous
êtes surtout les gemmes non je crois pas
mais celui-ci pression mundi rôle côté
jean michel merle merci jean michel mr
applaudissements pour lui on va
maintenant faire quelque chose qui va
devenir un rituel dans cette émission ça
s'appelle le j'aime j'aime pas chacun
d'entre eux voient une petite pancarte
regarder à côté de vous regarder denis
vous avez votre petite pancarte
voilà vous avez tous vos petit point car
c'est le j'aime j'aime pas dans touche
pas à mon poste d émission des
événements télé de la semaine
a vous de me dire si vous aimez ou si
vous n'aimez pas d'accord on va démarrer
avec le retour d'emmanuel chain à la
télé avec toujours autant de classe et
autant de sourcils j'aime bouger repas
j'aime alors christophe carrière n'aime
pas déjà non pourquoi
parce que j'aime pas les thèmes qui
avait dans l'émission fait les questions
posées tout ça c'est une émission
s'appelle haute définition il ya oui bah
oui justement c'était plutôt basse
définition sera il a décidé de casser ce
soir pourquoi vous n'aimiez pas quels
thèmes buzz attendait s'est dit m mais
j'ai un copain de mon fils voisins et
dealers c'est racoleur d'aunis non je
trouve que c'est courageux pour emmanuel
chain d'avoir tenté cette aventure en
prime time sur tf1
c'est rare et voilà c'est pour ça que
j'aime et vend plus
et puis toujours se souvenir d'eux et
quand f1 fait une émission comme ça on
tape dessus quand tf1 n'en fait pas on
dit bah ouais mais pourquoi il ya
toujours des films et téléfilms
exécution certaine c'était juste au lait
donc voilà je veux aller donc regarder
sur 7 je suis un peu d'accord avec vous
s'il y avait eu un thème un peu plus à
eyrans que cela aurait peut-être été
mieux c'est pas dit c'est pas tellement
encore qu'il est que les thèmes et et
racoleur que certes mais de la télé et
racoleuse dans son ensemble sur cette
stèle était déjà vu passer des thèmes
qu'on avait déjà vu un peu partout donc
estime déjà vu oui mais cela
particulièrement les positions chez
michel animateur jeunes aiment bien en
plus c'est quelqu'un qui avait abandonné
la télévision aux pme voir ce qui est
assez rare comme dans ce milieu là c'est
là qu'il n'a pas un ego surdimensionné
il ay revient donc à moi j'aime bien
mais j'aime bien les marges tandis que
j'aime parce qu'on vient de me dire que
c'était racoleur réputation t'adore et
ben moi aussi écouté j'ai regardé son
sourciller allez les fautes de français
de david charvet dans la ferme
célébrités est ce que vous aimez ou est
ce que vous n'aimez pas christophe
carrière tout de suite la vie j'aime
pourquoi ouais bah oui mais moi je
voudrais que dans la ferme et que des
gens comme ça non non non j'ai un accent
tour trop intelligent je trouve donner
vraiment que johnny sur jeu tf1 la ferme
et il n'aime pas non voilà je suis pas
si corps pas être que ça non mais c'est
surtout que j'aime pas et puis quand
j'en parle et j'ai l'impession enfants
de jane birkin avec cet accent cessé
faute de français juif voilà je suis je
pense qu'il peut parler beaucoup mieux
d'accord
jean michel vous aimez tout ce soir oui
mais il ya toujours d'un peu de blanc et
gris mais j'aime pas et je déteste la
ferme célébrités mais bâtiment où il ya
ce spectacle las si on n'aime pas les
n'essayez même pas les fautes
d'orthographe ou même pas regardé donc
j'aime uniquement les fautes
d'orthographe dans ce programme là c'est
le seul intérêt du programme conneries
mickaël vendetta c'est quand même le
seul intérêt de ce programme elodie vous
n'aimez pas la faire vous n'aimez pas
les fautes de français david charvet
dénoncé sur le c'est devenu trop
pathétique
et puis c'est comme touch peut paraître
rabat joie mais je pense qu'on a une
responsabilité
je connais plein de gamins qui regardent
et tout et voilà ça me dérange est-ce
qu'on vous avait contacté par l'afp
j'ai fait la première édition fait déjà
sur non non la tap à leur faire balancer
et vous tombiez moi je précise quand
même que david charvet est un étranger
en situation irrégulière c'était un
californien qui n'a pas de papiers et
donc qui comme elle est aux trois fautes
de français ça me semble pas vraiment
énorme et j'ai vu quand on va voir un
petit peu plus de considération et
surtout de d'amitié pour lui quoi merci
tendu allez on est bien dans touche pas
à mon poste denis brogniart et bien
depuis le début on ne lui fait que des
éloges et bien ça va se corser
figurez vous que ça va être le moment de
votre ca sa fin c'est le moment où je
dois partir on restait agité ici
attention dernier jeu maîtres nageurs
sont maintenant à la piscine vous ne
quitterai jamais la venturi si jamais
c'est vrai a oui c'est comme koh lanta
ici on ne part pas trop je me sens
toujours là lui mais ça va être le morro
n'a pas de morale thierry moreau va
poser toutes les questions dérangeantes
à denis brogniart moreau n'a pas de
morale
[Musique]
denis on accuse régulièrement koh lanta
de plus free alors on parle de
polystyrène cachés sous les radeaux pour
qu'il flotte de cocktails énergisante
donné par le médecin pour requinquer les
candidats alors si je vous apporte est
ce soir là sur ce plateau
la preuve indubitable que koh lanta est
riche est une tricherie est-ce que vous
démissionniez immédiatement nommé de ce
soit je peux répondre à toutes vos
questions et à toutes vos affirmations
concernant le cocktail notamment
effectivement quand le médecin de koh
lanta estime après une visite aux
candidats que ceux ci sont trop faibles
avant une épreuve
il peut leur donner ce que vous appelez
un cocktail énergisante c'est simplement
un jus de fruit un peu concentré pour
leur permettre de disputer cette épreuve
dans les meilleures conditions et sans
risquer de problèmes de santé sachez que
lorsqu'il ya un cocktail donné à un
aventurier le même et distribué à tous
variante si vous me dites on leur donne
à manger sur le campement
ils dorment pas par terre et cetera là
effectivement si vous me prouver le
contraire je démissionne instantanément
c'est ce qu'avait dit rien car
justement il ya une photo qu'on vous
voit vous faire maquiller à côté de deux
enfants et vous dis dans une région
reculée des philippines où il n'y a ni
eau ni électricité
alors moralement est ce que ça vous gêne
pas cette débauche de moyens pour une
émission de télé réalité dans quelques
fois des régions très pauvre pas du tout
parce qu'en plus c'est de l'une des
régions que j'ai le plus apprécié cette
péninsule de deux carats mohan il ya
effectivement peu d'électricité un ou
deux groupes électrogènes par village
qui alimente notamment une grande télé
parce qu'ils sont passionnés de karaoké
c'est rigolo
ils connaissent pas grand chose ils
vivent et ils sont souvent beaucoup plus
heureux que nous ça leur permet aussi de
vivre quelque chose d'assez incroyable
puisqu'il découvre la télévision et il
travaille aussi avec nous faut imaginer
quand il ya 80 français dans notre
équipe il ya 80 locaux qui viennent des
villages alentours de la zone de
tournage donc croyez moi on a participé
à un moment incroyable notamment là bas
et j'en veux pour preuve la fête de fin
de tournage où il y avait 1500 personnes
et où ça a été un truc rien de vous en
parler ça me donne encore des frissons
alors tous alors denis brogniart
d'hillary dans un village du faux du
karaoké sa sauce aux personnes mais
c'est ça qu'elle avait animé qui est
plus fort que benjamin castaldi qui est
plus fort que philippe lucas
qu'est-ce qui vous que ce que vous avez
été faire dans cette galère est ce que
vous avez été obligé par la chaîne est
ce que vous êtes le seul ami de benji ou
est-ce que c'était trop bien payés et
que les impôts arrive alors je vais vous
répondre très très franchement 1
je suis un
un très bon copain de benji et je
l'assumé et je suis pas l'un des seuls
jeux vous rassurons les deux je trouvais
que c'était rigolo de participer à cette
aventure je les fais surtout par plaisir
pour pouvoir avoir cette cette co
animation et cette partie de rigolade
avec benjamin pas ce qui m'amuse
beaucoup et puis franchement mais je
n'ai pas fait pour l'argent
même si c'est toujours important elle va
très bien mme applaudissements pour
thierry moral on a encore vu ce soir ça
s'est plutôt bien passé deux nuits
écoutez oui connectez vous en être bien
sorti 1 j'espère y arriver à toutes les
questions y compris sur la triche
barbade
il répond aux questions c'est pas comme
un homme politique lui répond allez on
va passer au top 5 des choses les plus
drôles qui se sont passés en télévision
cette semaine c'est dans touche pas à
mon poste regarder salut à tous et
bienvenue dans touche pas à mon top le
top 5 des moments les plus poignants de
la semaine en cinquième position de
jeunes bambins se sont déhanchés henry
reconnaît par exemple les romantiques
les endiablé
didon sa chope sur le dancefloor ici
comme dans les bons quand on était jeune
il y en a toujours deux qui font
tapisserie en face au quatrième de notre
top poilades attention la vanne la plus
drôle de ce début de siècle
j'en suis toujours pas remise la sphère
et moore c'est quand même incroyable
d'abord disons le on a pas vraiment de
preuve mais d'après la plupart des
femmes qui ont bien voulu témoigner j'ai
dit la plupart des femmes à tout
zemmour n'est vraiment pas une affaire
et voilà tellement pourri la vanne
qu'elle en devient hilarante il est fort
ce recueil est en troisième position on
passe au jeu de mots je viens vers vous
dites que le décor du suppositoire est
entré dans les annales mais je sais que
cette coquine
on dirait pas comme ça mais elle et pas
farouche marina et on reste dans la
thématique des annales avec l'heureuse
élue à la deuxième place du top
australien
enfin
alors ça a été dur oui c'est dur mais
quand je transpire on récolte du sperme
est vrai car c'est un nouveau métier
celui moi c'est jean pierre je suis un
sticker d'éléphant attention c'est un
métier à risque
l'un d'entre eux a eu un oeil au beurre
noir à cause d'un coup de tennis à ça
peut faire mal l'amour vache est à la
première place de notre top cette
semaine un fermier qui a trop du jouet
avec les éléphants de la savane
lui parler
ça va faire du bien bel orage assez sur
un orage a rien de tel pour se
rafraîchir les idées
allez un petit pour la route et c'est
cadeau ça va faire du bien bel ouvrage
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir comparé ce top 5 des
moments les plus drôles de la télé nous
on a adoré ça vous a plu
c'est énorme allez on va faire un petit
jeu maintenant les émissions télé du
poste nous propose des émissions vous me
dîtes si elle existe ou pas une émission
propose à des journalistes d'avaler des
cachets d'ecstasy et de faire l'amour
avec deux inconnues pendant l'heure qui
suit possible ou pas possible aux
pays-bas précise fabrice moreau ça
existe aux pays-bas
ça s'appelle fulton flickr et c'est tout
les drogues lincecum qui donne comme
denis brillant yeux ton par contre en
néerlandais tu l'avais pris en première
langue oui c'est ça top je suis très
très tendance l'icn ouais mais tu me dis
quand même pas 100 affiche base ils
essayent jeux pour iphone en silicone
une émission propose à des millionnaires
de vivre dix jours à la rue dans la peau
d'un sdf possible ou pas possible
possible possible et oui aux états unis
et sur une chaîne espagnole aussi sur
kobe n'a réussi leur fiche des fipol
fortunés vivent dix jours dans la peau
d'un sdf ça c'est nul
voilà une petite dernière tient celle ci
une émission propose à christine bravo
et jean louis borloo de survivre une
semaine dans un bar avec une seule
bouteille de whisky par jour et par
personne possible ou pas possible c'est
parce que ce serait bien on sera ça
serait bien ce serait une belle émission
tandis possible c'est possible à
condition qu'on y ajoute olivier de
kersauson je pense
merci tanguy la partie verte et ça casse
mais il va partir lâche t elle à la
rentrée j'ai eu des infos
alors là on annule tout celle alerte
enlèvement on reprend notre sérieux
alerte enlèvement les programmes sont
interrompus sur france télévisions
allez-y c'est à vous
ceci est une alerte enlèvement sylvain
mirouf a été enlevé il a été vu la
dernière fois en 2004 en train d'animer
euromillionnaire sur france 3 d'après
les témoins le magicien réussi le plus
beau tour de sa carrière en se faisant
disparaître des écrans de télévision
malgré lui il serait vêtu d'une cape
d'un chapeau et disposerait d'après sa
femme d'une baguette magique de 15 cm si
et seulement si vous disposez
d'informations permettant de le
retrouver
contacter le standard de l'émission
touche pas à mon poste
votre mobilisation est essentielle pour
nous et surtout pour lui
merci à vous deux
mobilisés c'est vrai qu'on en rigole
mais l' alerte enlèvement a permis de
retrouver des enfants disparus et si tu
vraiment une bonne initiative j'espère
qu'on retrouvera sylvain mirouf de nice
et du votre livre et j'ai vous vous
connaissez tous tous les candidats tout
ce qui s'est passé vous n'avez rien
oublié
on va faire un petit jeu je vous
proposais des noms des équipes de koh
lanta a vous de me dire si elle existe
ou pas d'accord d'accord les ventes anas
et les tambours koh lanta ou pas
kolontar vente annoncée tambour c'est
koh lanta quand vous choisissez les noms
je comprends pas assez un brainstorming
c'est vraiment des réunions extrêmement
intense dans la production de tf1 ce que
van thanh ha soit l'impression que c'est
un gars ashba donc va donc chez des non
qui pique les endroits où il y avait
tant bord c'était à au costa rica si je
ne m'abuse
et c'était 2 le nom d'une ville un petit
village qui était pas très loin de
l'endroit ont tourné est-ce que les
témesta xanax ça existe mais pas dans
koh lanta d'autre que l'autre les
machines gars oui les machines gaza
exige existe alors les machines car on a
l'impression que ce sont les cousins des
types qui king alors autres tous les
matches les [ __ ] hausse non koh
lanta ou pas koh lanta les enfoiros ce
we non non j'en avais est ce qu a eu un
candidat qui a été insupportable dans
koh lanta notre candidat détester sans
langue de bois a franchement non
maintenant on attend c'est plutôt tour
gérer alors posé des questions sous la
main y en a bien que vous avez détesté
détesté pas forcément il ya un candidat
qui se reconnaîtra effectivement que
j'avais pensé dès le début parce qu'il
avait été particulièrement arrogant
voire blessant avec les jeunes femmes
aller sur une bonne santé pour des
missions deal
très drôle mais c'est pas un peu triché
ah non non pas du tout c'était la
deuxième saison je vous donnerai pas son
prénom voilà donc pour la réponse est
donc parti pour garder ce soir vous
n'êtes pas dans le livre la saint
patrick
ce n'est pas pareil aller au travail ou
plusieurs c'est patrick j'en suis sûr un
fait patrie allez regarder à côté de
vous il à l'homme le plus chevelu de
france christophe carrière christophe
carrière chaque semaine il va
s'intéresser à un invité qui est en
promo qu'est ce que c'est que la promo
c'est à dire qu'un invité un comédien
chanteur en sportive va faire de la
promotion dans des émissions comme par
exemple frank leboeuf pour koh lanta
d'ailleurs et nous allons c'est qu'il
avait gagné et bien cette semaine
christophe carrière s'est intéressée à
judith godrèche c'est la promotion de
son film et c'est le meilleur vendeur de
la semaine la vendeuse oui c'est une
femme non non non non sur jonah sur elle
a réalisé un film s'appelle toutes les
filles pleurent ça la concerne
voilà et qu'elle a écrit joué chanté
mise en scène c'est à dire en gros c'est
là la motivation raté aussi c'est vrai
on peut le dire mais c'est la motivation
de l'ade la force pas même la puissance
de feu de la vendeuse était donc partout
où elle a fait le grand journal on n'est
pas couché thé ou café star mag
enfin elle l a fait vraiment toutes les
étapes principales du parc pour vip
cinéma et sa grande angoisse à judith
godrèche c'est d'avoir des tics de
langage judith on est bien intentionnés
ci est donc on en a relevé un
significatif à ne pas trop répéter une
vraie spontanéité et c'est vrai que les
saintes écritures a toujours été
présente vraiment envie de
elle est vraiment l'adresse part du fisc
un joueur me sens vraiment c'est
vraiment les souvenirs sensuelle je me
suis vraiment c'est pas vrai un vrai
film romanesque c'est vraiment pourquoi
ouais ouais ouais vous l'avez compris
judith godrèche est dans le vrai voilà
un vrai discours un véritable
enthousiasme de vrais seins de vrai dans
deux précieux enfin tout est vrai bon le
film est pas terrible d'accord mais je
suis pas loin d'aller le revoir
tellement judy toi je l'appelle
juridique parce que c'est très joli donc
tellement elle le vend bien ben moi j'ai
envie de le revoir
d'autant que je peux y apprendre des
choses sur lui dit ouais ouais non non
parce qu'on on y a une chose je vois que
vous commencez à vous entendre
j'aime bien chez moi là bas ceci parce
qu'en fait elle s'y met à nu dans les
interviews et dont le film aussi mais
vraiment à nu un nu ben voilà oui je
savais que ça vous intéresse dans le
projet des semaines où on fait j'entends
par là qu elle y dévoile son âme
voilà ça vous excite - déjà un il ya une
part de mon enfance mais de mon enfance
réinventer voilà avec les années qui
passent je pense que l'inconscient se
chargent de réécrire l'histoire et en
même temps les souvenirs avec le temps
sont réinventés par l'inconscient et je
suivais beaucoup dans l'imaginaire et
l'inconscient a réécrit l'histoire
cette recherche du du du vrai moi à la
légère du vrai moi la recherche du vrai
- n'est-ce pas là un argument de vente
formidable on va aller voir le vrai j'ai
vraiment aimé le film
ça s'appelle toutes les filles pleurent
mais enfin bon c'est vraiment si on
adore j2 rech
mais bon ici on adore le cinéma
peut-être bon pouvoir l'affirmer mais
bon si vous aimez judith godrèche allez
le voir si vous aimez le cinéma
restez chez vous et regardez touche pas
à mon poste continuer à regarder la
télévision merci christophe carrière
la semaine prochaine les portes arrière
s'intéressera un autre meilleur vendeur
de la semaine et cela provoque les
soirées des promos il y en a toutes les
semaines je vais vous demander
maintenant de redevenir sérieux on n'a
plus de nouvelles de lui depuis des
années la france est sans nouvelles de
l'un de ses plus grands journalistes
spécialistes des ovnis alors qu'est-il
devenu
at il été kidnappé par les martiens les
frères bogdanoff l'ont-il kidnappé c'est
assez incroyable questions que nous
allons tenter de répondre ce soir car
après des années de recherches
nous l'avons retrouvée je vous demande
d'applaudir et d'accueillir celui qui a
tutoyé les extraterrestres jean claude
bourret merci d'être là ce soir
votre grand retour à la télévision dans
touche pas à mon poste
quel plaisir quel honneur jean-claude
vous aviez dit que vous ne referiez plus
jamais de télé ce soir vous êtes avec
nous pourquoi
et bien tout simplement parce que vous
me l'avez demandé et ben voilà pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas jean claude
bourret jean claude bourret ans est une
légende de la télévision regardez donc
quelques dizaines de secondes l'a5 va
mourir en sac
[Applaudissements]
la fin de la saint jean claude bourret
alors quand vous voyez ces images
et oui c'est toujours émouvant parce que
je me souviens qu'au moment où ces
images ont été diffusées ou l'a5 c'est
vraiment éteinte les téléspectateurs
d'ailleurs pensé que c'était quelque
chose qui était bidon parce qu'il disait
au dernier moment ils vont de le sortir
à lapin du chapeau
et puis pas du tout la 5 cette étape
mais je me souviens de mon assistante
qui est venu pleurer sur mon épaule et
ça ça m'a beaucoup marqué il y avait un
silence d'or dans la rédaction
oui avait plein de téléspectateurs qui
étaient rentrés on a vu sur des images
et il ya eu un vraiment un silence total
c'était très impressionnant et donc
après cet arrêt qu'est ce qui s'est
passé après cet arrêt tout le monde a
été au chômage plus ou moins moi je suis
resté un an au chômage et d'ailleurs
quand je faisais là la queue à l'anpe
les gens pensaient que c'était pour une
caméra cachée drees qui pensait pas qu
un présentateur un peu connus puisse
être au chômage bas ça se remplace
jean-claude quand même présentateur
vedette présentateur du jt du week-end
sur tf1 de 1975 à 1987 présentateur du
jt de la 5 13 heures puis du week-end
vous avez été et débuté sur france inter
comment on se retrouve comme ça du jour
au lendemain sans rien quand on est un
animateur vedette pendant un an j'ai
tourné en rond avec mon ma paye de
chômeurs et puis ensuite radio
monte-carlo va récupérer et j'ai terminé
ma carrière à rmc
et alors parlez nous un peu long mais on
m'a dit que vous étiez colonel quand les
gendarmes ont eu un petit problème de
communication
il ya une dizaine d'années vous savez
quand certains gendarmes avaient brûlé
les fameuses paillote qu'on n'arrivait
pas à éradiquer sur l'île corse
l'image la gendarmerie en a pris il faut
donc la direction de la gendarmerie a
fait appel à quelques spécialistes de la
communication dans votre serviteur est
depuis dix ans je suis conseiller du
directeur de gendarmerie pour la
communication denis peut-être une
question pour jean claude
non moi je suis très heureux en tout cas
de le rencontrer parce que on s'était
jamais rencontré on n'a jamais travaillé
ensemble dans une question toute simple
est ce que quand on est à la com de la
gendarmerie on est tranquille avec les
pv les points sur son permis
alors c'est très marrant c'est une très
bonne question je remercie de l'avoir
posée
non parce que j'ai jamais fait sauter un
pv de ma vie pour moi en ce qui me
concerne et
deuxièmement maintenant on a un système
informatique qui fait qu' on ne peut
plus du tout faire sauter les pv
donc c'est certain que je donne mon
numéro de portable non ça ne sert à rien
mais la lettonie les applaudissements
pour jean claude bauer du cac et avec
tout ce soir djoko est avec nous
j'espère que vous allez revenir très
souvent dans l'émission vous venez quand
vous voulez vous êtes chez vous ici on
va refaire un nouveau j'aime j'aime pas
et avant de faire le j'aime j'aime pas
jean-claude vous pouvez me refaire un
petit mesdames messieurs bonsoir face
caméra là ça nous ferait tellement du
bien ça va quand même
allez-y bada mademoiselle monsieur
bonjour il a rien perdu
allez on va se refaire un j'aime j'aime
pas vous regarder la télévision jean
claude bien sûr je regarde la télévision
et ben donc vous allez pouvoir jouer
avec nous oh j'aime j'aime pas c'est
tout de suite la deuxième partie
[Musique]
vous avez des petites contacter si vous
aimez djm si vous n'aimez pas vous dites
j'aime passer sur des événements télé de
la semaine après la méthode cauet la
cauetidienne ça va secouer le nouveau
super jeu de mots de la nouvelle
émission de cauet ce qu'on aime moi ce
qu'on n'aime pas ça va secouer
ça va secouer ça va secouer alors de ce
côté on aime tous de ce côté il ya que
de nyc & corporate forcément je parle
même pas de l'émission je veux que c'est
drôle c'est marrant de ces voilà
exactement ça donc ça moi je vous je
vous comprends christophe vous n'aimez
pas quelques années c'était vraiment une
purge cette émission j'ai regardé ça
dure et ça durait des plombes ça
commençait à pas d'or j'ai regardé
c'était vachement moins drôle non non
non non vraiment c'est lui qui corporate
s'est niché dans le sud je me suis
absolument nuit ya ce genre michel
moi j'aime pas ce que je trouve que koei
c'était quelqu'un qui a énormément de
talent et je trouve qu'il le gâche un
peu en faisant un peu toujours la même
chose la même mayonnaise justice il
pourrait faire bien d'autres choses ça
en revanche quand il ya une chose qu'il
faut dire et ça c'est vrai c'est que
c'est lui la vedette alors qu'il en
fasse si l'agent et nous l'agad elmaleh
il avait un plateau d'enfer et c'est lui
la vedette hier en vendée on se dit non
et gars c'est pas toi la vedette
et moi j'adore le professionnalisme de
cauet et moi j'adore le divertissement à
la télé donc je suis déçu c'est la même
région
la région elle défend les picards est la
raison vous traîner un tanguy ben je
trouve que ça va secouer
c'est marrant comme titre parce que ça
prouve que laurent ruquier travaille
aussi pour tf1 s'est surpris est ce que
vous aimez michel cymes le docteur
français qui cartonne sur france 5 en
parlant d'hémorroïdes à l'heure du
déjeuner jean michel vous n'aimez pas
alors j'aime parce que malheureusement
je trouve que c'est assez facile de
faire des blagues sur la médecine sûr
danser les annales
tout ça à chaud des blagues justement il
faut démystifier les gens sont inquiets
oui justement c'est pas lui victoire de
nice si c'est quand même vachement
anxiogène on parle le problème or s'il
n'y a pas que les hémorroïdes y attend
autant de vrais problèmes beaucoup plus
graves
mais ça fait du bien de parler il fait
preuve de charité
oui mais j'aime bien parce qu'il faut
effectivement mélanger le côté sérieux
et scientifique n'a médecins à part
entière et en même temps il m'a sens de
l'humour que je trouve vraiment génial
ils aiment tous jean claude bourret il
est tellement sympa alors il audi vous
adorez moi j'adore j'adore les
réflexions et puis effectivement c'est
une façon d'attirer aussi les gens et de
rendre les choses voilà plus à porter
c'est une belle série avec drôle sur le
service public à part vous y avait pas
brabham et merci tanguy vous n'aimez pas
pourquoi non j'aime pas du tout parce
que je déteste en règle générale les
gens qui ont de l'humour
autant je me dévoue
merci à vous d'avoir fait le jeune jaime
pas jean-claude l'ouest avec new delhi
également vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
c'est les cinq ans de la tnt
alors on dit souvent que la tnt c'est un
petit peu le souhait indien le soutien
historique
vous avez différence et sur des
programmes complètement différent de ce
que je peux faire sur tf1 moi je prends
beaucoup de plaisir en tout cas
notamment à faire les secrets de la
magie et domino day qui est quand même
jeu juste un ovni dans le paysage
audiovisuel français et je suis très
attaché à ce programme parce que
personne n'y croyait tf1 la première
année et on était quasiment 10 millions
de téléspectateurs à l'époque c'est vrai
que ça allait bien bien qui a donné la
première année je vois valeur hypnotique
du programme comme disait le faire des
trucs qui tombe pas des nues commenté
ils se sont dit ça il faut appeler denis
brogniart avec des airs aussi alain
duhamel l'a fait avec le modem aux
dernières élections
ce sont donc les cinq ans de la tnt et
chacun d'entre vous a choisi une image
qui symbolise la tnt qui symbolise une
des chaînes de la tnt thierry moreau
vous avez choisi quoi j'ai choisi w9
parce que c'est la petite soeur de m6 a
fait partie du même groupe il ya une
petite fille qui s'appelle asap présager
un camille combal c'est une petite bulle
comme ça de d'intelligence et de
drôlerie mais franchement si tu puisses
faire je vous propose de voir un tout
petit je voterai ces voix-là cc diffusée
tous les soirs et vraiment c'est à ne
pas manquer c'est quand on parle de
menton pense souvent sera bogdanov et
bien maintenant plus du tout on pensa à
solide d'oeuvres réalisées dans un
célèbre fast food de la ville de menton
et oui il faudra pas l'oublier par
devoir de mémoire pour que plus jamais
cela ne se reproduise
tous les jours il reprend quasiment j'ai
la foi de la télévision ou du net
et il en fait une petite chronique très
très drôle et franchement c'est un
problème beaucoup camille combal c'est
un ami et d'ailleurs je suis sûr qu'il
nous regardons lembras jean michel maire
vous avez choisi quoi plus sérieusement
j'ai choisi une image sur bfm bfm qui
était là la radio d'information qui
faisait l'événement l'époque c'était au
début c'est bien tout animal j'ai pas
d'argent il y avait seulement deux du
direct le matin et le soir le reste
c'était un tuyau un peu info
pourrissement ils sont aguerris ils ont
fait sur tous les coups ils ont fait les
coûts avec des débats entre les deux
tours des primaires du ps avant
l'élection présidentielle et surtout
entre les deux tours ils ont fait des
interviews et juste après le premier
tour des interviews d'hommes politiques
dont notamment celle de nicolas sarkozy
qu'avec a quand même fait beaucoup par
jean jacques bourdin qui fait le mug
tous les matins rodamco on regarde
nicolas sarkozy vous savez que nous
avons une tradition rmc nous aiderons
les sous marins non je vous avais
entendu parler des des sous marins alors
combien la france possède elle possède
d'elle deux sous marins nucléaires
d'attaqué 4 4,5 sous marin nucléaire
d'attaqué s'inquiéter alors il ya un
côté prof d'école un peu qui évidemment
qu'un peu déplaisant mais enfin ça fait
le buzz qu'il a fait un peu avec
ségolène royal avec tous les candidats
avec ryan on a vu cela prenne cette
chaîne bat plus forte qu'elle l'est
parce que maintenant c'est la première
chaîne d'info en continu mais j'adore un
casse ça tu as tu géré l'impression
d'être dans pyramide tanguy pastureau
vous avez choisi quoi pourront terminera
en beauté par elodie gossuin pas en
beauté par mois non malheureusement très
bien pour mes 50 de la tnt enfin l'image
vraiment qui m'a marqué c'est celle ci
voilà l'image de mon décodeur tnt c'est
mon premier thème mon premier des
leaders et c'est ce que j'ai trouvé le
plus beau possible
alors moi je suis fan de fort boyard
alors vous allez me dire c'est sur
france 2 bah oui mais qui dit fort
boyard dit père fouras dix énigmes
maître du temps votre style au perchoir
j'adore j'adore et moi le moment
cultissime de ces cinq dernières années
de tnt c'est sur direct8 également parce
que passe-partout n'est pas que le
gardien des clés de son voyage est aussi
chanteur et il nous a offert un moment
cultissime mémorable sur la chaîne je
vous laisse découvrir ou redécouvrir
c'est juste magique
je suis un jeudi de l'es15 que dans les
dragues main qui rêve
sue est d'abord
oui
je suis partout du fort boyard
je sonne le gong du grand est
l'esprit du type est toujours
j'aime bien ce joueur de se quitter
il vient un rituel dans cette émission
denis brogniart ça s'appelle le quiz du
post le quiz du pote vous allez passer
au pupitre denis et on va vous
interroger sur des émissions télé vous
allez voir des images d'émissions télé
vous allez avoir une minute pour
découvrir le plus d'émissions télé dès
que vous ne savez pas vous passer
attention une minute le quiz du post
c'est parti vite c'est quoi ça [ __ ] il
est mort yapo l'on allait se passer
d'eric c'est bon allez le jt de 13
heures oui c'est bon on passe sous le
soleil non pas du tout c'était desperate
housewives opus à olive qui a lui c'est
c'est quoi ces c dans l'air c'est dans
l'air bonnes réponses
allez le taratata nagui s'il vous plaît
bien sûr aller sachez pas on sait pas
fêter le téléshopping d'axa je suis pas
non plus heroes à l'esa koh lanta et
tony koh lanta avec tony exactement à
l'est attention à la marche c'est bon
bonne réponse c'est bon les chiffres
laissent aller à l'aller vrai qu'ils ont
pas sur top chef c'est ok en prochaine
théo pelo dit elodie le capital capital
bonnes réponses
il reste cinq secondes à l'est c'est
quoi ça mais gilles brenon c'est pas mal
laisse glisser le rugby s'est passé
or c'est dans laquelle sont le temps
qu'ils volent les sacs l'indus mais deux
niveaux la révolte
mais loin de là à côté de moi olalala
elodie gossuin a beaucoup souffert
attention plus a toujours nié grognards
de nick est ce que vous êtes devant vous
je suis pleine croissance mais qu'est-ce
que je suis petit mois c'est surtout ça
en plus a way non j'ai une sarkozettes
non mais il a une espèce de petite
portée la volée et venez venez venez pas
venir montrer aux téléspectateurs
regardent chez une petite règle est là
c'est normal
là c'est la position hanouna hanouna
merci oui c'est mon président notre
président qui m'est offerte si cette
petite mercy de lits de niveler secrets
de koh lanta denis brogniart on apprend
plein de choses sur koh lanta vraiment
je me suis régalé arthur merci c'est à
françois oui ce qui vous a aidé
également de télé loisirs télé loisirs
qu'on embrasse également signer dean et
dan on ferait passer n'est dnc d'ado
préface 1 1 ça c'est super mais quand
vous avez fait pour la voir zinedine
zidane j'ai eu la chance de le
rencontrer plusieurs fois notamment sur
les grands prix de formule 1 parce que
c'est un passionné de voitures et c'est
à ce moment là qu'il m'a dit qu'il
regardait koh lanta souvent et que ces
quatre garçons donc voilà je vais
proposer d'écrire la préface et il m'a
répondu favorablement avec beaucoup de
plaisir donc est ce une grande fierté
pour moi en tout cas qu'elle imaginait
bras
denis brogniart koh lanta tf1 monte
20h45 un bien sûr avec la victoire de
franck leboeuf donc calmez-vous un
soutenez-le vous savez qui va gagner
mais moi je regardais quote merci denis
merci christophe carrière merci jean
michel galant c'est la première fois que
tu es tu meurs à mogador merci thierry
maugez en train de faire le break à la
salle audio secrecy tanguy pastureau et
verse également et jean claude bourret
arrondissement dont jean todt si vous
aimez les émissions médias ne les
manquez pas nos vous attend la semaine
prochaine 22h40 et nous ici on se
prendra jamais la tête
n est ce pas de ninon est ce que la télé
c'est que de la terre ils sont
formidables merci à tous et la semaine
prochaine oh la la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]